Guten Tag, mein Name ist Genj, heute bin ich Ihre Ärzte.
Bevor wir mit dem Anamnesegespräch anfangen, möchte ich Ihre persönliche Daten aufnehmen.
Ist das in Ordnung für Sie?
Ja, natürlich, ja.
Sehr gut, wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Klaus Schall.
Können Sie Ihre Vor- und Nachnamen durchstabieren?
Ja, Klaus, K-L-A-U-S.
Ja, Nachname.
Und der Familienname Schall-S-C-H-A-Doppel-L.
Okay, ja, Herr Schall. Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 33 Jahre alt.
33 Jahre alt. Wahnsinn sind Sie geboren.
Am 18. Mai 1990.
1990.
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ich wiege so 98 Kilo.
98? Wie groß sind Sie?
1,86.
1,86. Okay. Herr Schall, was für eine Sekunde zum Jahr?
Ja, also ich habe seit Tagen solche Kopfschmerzen, hier vor allen Dingen auf der linken Seite.
Und die werden immer schlimmer.
Und das hat sachte angefangen, habe ich gedacht, okay, gut, ein bisschen Kopfschmerzen ist ja nicht so schlimm.
Aber jetzt brennt es und zieht.
Und wenn ich mich ein bisschen bewege, habe ich das Gefühl, es wird immer schlimmer.
Und die Schmerzen, die strahlen, also hier so richtig in den Hinterkopf rein
und bis in die Schulter und in den Arm.
Ich habe das Gefühl, das tut mir alles weh.
Und ich kann mich eigentlich auch nicht so richtig gut bewegen.
Ich habe da so ein bisschen Widerstand.
Und das ist so schlimm, dass ich jetzt die Tage gar nicht mehr schlafen konnte.
Okay. Haben Sie die Beschwerde nun auf der linken Seite?
Ja, ja, auf der linken Seite ist das, ja, genau.
Seit mehrere Tagen haben Sie gesagt, oder?
Ja, genau. Also das hätt so vor vier Tagen angefahren, war am Anfang nicht so schlimm.
Und jetzt wird es aber mit der Zeit immer heftiger.
Und ja, jetzt fühle ich mich wirklich schon schlecht.
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass mir schon schlecht ist, vor allem auf der linken Seite.
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass mir schon schlecht ist vor Schmerzen, ja.
Okay, ist das erst mal aufgetreten?
Ich kann mich nicht erinnern, dass ich solche Schmerzen schon einmal hatte.
Leiden Sie normalerweise an Kopfschmerzen?
Nein, ich bin eigentlich kein so Kopfschmerzmensch, nee.
Okay, also wir können davon ausgehen, dass Sie erst mal solche Kopfschmerzen haben.
Ja, also, so was habe ich noch nicht gehabt.
Okay, haben Sie Leben, Sprach, Störungen bemerkt?
Also, was ich gemerkt habe, dass die linke Hand so ein bisschen zitterig ist.
Okay.
Ja, das ist mir aufgefallen.
Okay, können Sie die Schmerzen auf eine Schmerzskale einschätzen?
Von 1 bis 10.
Eins sehr leicht und 10 sehr starke Schmerzen.
Also auf alle Fälle mehr als die Hälfte, das sind keine Schmerzen, die man gut ertragen kann.
Also, ich würde vielleicht sagen, so 6, weil 6 sind die wohl ja.
Natürlich.
Haben Sie Bluthochdruck?
Nein, in meinem Alter.
Was soll ich Bluthochdruck haben?
Also, ich bin ja eigentlich ganz gesund.
Nee, ich habe eigentlich sonst nie irgendein Schmerz.
Deswegen irritiert mich das auch so, dass ich diese Schmerzen habe.
Okay.
Sind Sie gestürzt vor 4 Tagen? Hatten Sie einen Unfall?
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Es befindet sich keinen Unfall.
Es gab keinen Unfall, nein.
Haben Sie Fieberstilfrost?
Nein, nein, nein.
Da habe ich ganz sicher nicht.
Nein, ich habe auch nicht geschwitzt oder schüttelfrost.
Nein, nee, sowas habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Verschlümmern sich die Schmerzen beim Kaunen?
Beim Kaunen?
Ja.
Also, ich habe das Gefühl, mehr so bei größeren Bewegungen,
dass dann die Schmerzen stärker werden.
Und dass ich deswegen mich weniger bewege,
jetzt, dass ich so ein bisschen eine Schonhaltung habe.
Aber nur beim Kopf drehen oder nicht?
Ja, würde ich sagen.
Ja, und ich kann mich natürlich auch nicht gut bücken oder so.
Okay.
Und haben Sie tränende Augen?
Das ist mir nicht aufgefallen, nee.
Rötung bei den Augen?
Nee, Rötung oder tränende Augen, das kriege ich immer nur im Frühling,
wenn so eine hohe Pollenbelastung,
ich habe so eine Pollenalläge,
dann habe ich tränende und rote Augen, aber jetzt nicht.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme mit Ursula-Sanstuhlgang?
Ist das in Ordnung?
Nein, das ist alles ganz normal.
Okay.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit Gewicht verloren?
Nein, also ich wiege mich jetzt nicht ständig,
aber ich glaube, das ist schon ewig lange stabil.
Das ist Ihnen nicht aufgefallen?
Nein, nein.
Okay.
Sie haben keine chronische Erkrankungen, oder?
Nein, das Einzige, was ich habe,
ich habe seit fünf Jahren auf der rechten Seite so ein Ohrgeräusch.
Ja?
Nein.
Da ist man nicht so richtig sicher, ob das stressbedingt ist
oder so, das ist auch nicht immer,
ist auch mehr oder weniger unangenehm.
Aber das ist auch das Einzige, was ich dagegen mache,
ich mache auch nichts.
Haben Sie einen Ohrarzt besucht dafür?
Ja, ja, ich war da mal beim Arzt, beim heißen Ohrenarzt
und er konnte aber jetzt irgendwie keine Ursache feststellen.
Okay.
Wurden Sie schon mal operiert?
Als Kind hatte ich mal einen Armbruch,
der operativ wieder gerichtet werden musste.
Da hatte ich einen Fahrradunfall, der war so acht Jahre alt.
Und der war irgendwie ein bisschen kompliziert gebrochen
und dann hat man das operiert, aber das war jetzt keine
langbierige Operation, keine große Geschichte.
Okay.
Welche Seite?
Der linke Unterarmbruch gebrochen.
Linke Unterarm.
Gibt es noch weitere Operationen?
Nein, nein, sonst ist noch alles dran.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamente ein?
Nein, also überhaupt nicht.
Wenn ich, wenn ich im Sommer, also im Frühjahr so Schnupfen,
also diese Pollenallergie habe, dann nehme ich mal so Nasenspray,
aber das ist auch alles.
Okay.
Was ist der Name des Medikaments?
Das sind nur so normale Kochseiztropfen.
Ah, okay.
Sie sind nur so sehr zional, oder?
Ja, ja.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit viel Medikament eingenommen?
Ja, überhaupt nichts.
Rauchen Sie?
Ja, aber wenig.
Also ich rauch vielleicht so fünf, sechs Zigaretten am Tag.
Weißt du, in den Pausen bei der Arbeit, eine vielleicht mal mal so zum Feierabend, aber...
Und seit wann rauchen Sie?
Wann habe ich damit angefangen?
Ja, so vor zwölf Jahren ungefähr.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, im Alltag eigentlich nicht.
Man muss ja morgen früh aufstehen und zur Arbeit fit sein.
Am Wochenende trinke ich, wo man Papier oder ein Glas Wein oder ein Cocktail oder so.
Aber wirklich nur am Wochenende.
Oder bei Festen, bei Feiern oder so.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Haben Sie Erfahrung mit Drogen?
Mit Drogen habe ich keine Erfahrung.
Jetzt hätte ich einige Frage zu Ihrer Familie.
Haben Ihre Eltern oder soweit Sie haben Ihre Geschwister Kronscharkrankungen?
Lassen Sie mich überlegen.
Weil mein Vater, da hat man vor zwei Jahren so ein Stand in die Herzgefäße eingesetzt.
Da war seitdem, geht es dem eigentlich ziemlich gut und ist der wieder ganz fit.
Und meine Mutter hat eigentlich keine weiteren Erkrankungen.
Die hat Knieprobleme, aber keine inneren Erkrankungen oder so was.
Und meine Schwester ist ein Jahr, zwei Jahre älter als ich.
Die ist total gesund.
Leiden Ihre Mutter an Gelenkfallschleiß?
Ja, die hatte irgendwie eine Knieoperation, die hat ein neues Kniegelenk bekommen.
Weil das rechte Knie irgendwie kaputt war.
Aber nicht nach dem Unfall, sondern jagen sie durch Verschleiß.
Okay, es besteht keine Rheuma oder fröhliche Rheuma-Tate.
Rheuma oder so hat die nicht, nee, nee.
Okay. Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Angestellter bei der Stadt.
Ich arbeite im Einwohner-Melderamt.
Also Sie arbeiten in einem Büro?
Genau, viel am Computer natürlich.
Aber auch hin und wieder Kontakt eben mit Bürgern, die dann hier in das Einwohneramt kommen.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Nein, ich bin unverheiratet.
Okay, Sie sind ledig.
Nein, Kinder habe ich auch nicht.
Haben Sie einen Partner oder wohnen Sie allein?
Ich wohne mit meiner Freundin zusammen, ja.
Jetzt möchte ich kurz kontrollieren, ob ich alles richtig aufgeschrieben habe oder nichts.
Okay.
Haben Sie dieses Gefühl oder hatten Sie dieses Gefühl, dass Sie, bevor die Schmerzen angefangen haben,
ein Lichtbelitze oder Geruchempfindlichkeits, Lichtscheu und solche Sachen,
haben Sie gehabt?
Nein, nein, nein. Das fing eigentlich ja ganz langsam an.
Und ja, man merkt dann, dass man Kopfschmerzen hat, ja.
Das ging langsam los und dann wurde es eben immer schlimmer und wollte überhaupt nicht wieder weggehen.
Okay, Sie sind immer da?
Ja, jetzt sind Sie immer da, die Schmerzen, ja.
Seit eben, seit vier Tagen.
Deswegen kann ich auch, es erschöpft mich natürlich, wenn ich immer Kopfschmerzen habe.
Können Sie gut schlafen seit vier Tagen oder haben Sie auch Internet?
Nein, normalerweise kann ich wohl schlafen, es sei denn, es ist mal wirklich sehr, sehr viel los bei der Arbeit
oder man hat mal Ärger. Aber eigentlich, jetzt in den letzten Tagen konnte ich so gut wie gar nicht schlafen.
Also hatte ich das Gefühl, ich schlafe nicht.
Ich bin morgens immer so ein bisschen kaputt aufgewacht und fühlte mich immer schlapp und müde.
Okay, haben Sie Stress bei der Arbeit?
Momentan.
Momentan geht es, aber das gibt immer mal so Phasen, wo viel Betrieb ist, ja.
Aber es stört Sie nicht so viel.
Doch, also manchmal ist es schon stressig und ja, je nachdem gibt es schon wieder neue Vorgesetzte
oder es gibt neue Mitarbeiter, mit denen man nicht so gut kann.
Also hin und wieder ist es schon stressig.
Okay.
Aber nicht jetzt im Augenblick kann ich das nicht sagen.
Sind Sie in den letzten Tagen schwindelig geworden oder Ihren Bewusstsein verloren?
Das Bewusstsein habe ich nicht verloren, nein, nein.
Schwindelig waren Sie eigentlich auch nicht, das kann ich nicht sagen.
Okay.
Haben Sie keine Medikamente gegen diese Schmerzen eingenommen?
Haben Sie nicht probiert?
Ja, ich habe mal probiert.
Als es dann so zugenommen hat, da habe ich zweimal Aspirin genommen.
Aber es hat irgendwie so gut wie gar nichts verändert.
Mhm.
Aber die hatte ich noch irgendwie so als Notfallreserve in meinem Beidezimmer gefunden
und da habe ich die mal genommen.
Ja, aber wie gesagt, das hat nicht viel gebracht.
Mhm.
Und Sie sind erst mal bei einem Arzt, oder?
Ja, ja, ich bin damit jetzt noch nicht beim Arzt gewesen.
Okay.
Und haben Sie bis auf einen Zittern auf der linke Hand keine Lemungen bemerkt?
Lemungen oder so, wie gesagt, diese Hand, die hat man so ein bisschen gezittert,
das ist aber auch nicht andauern, sondern hin und wieder.
Haben Sie Probleme bei anderen Glieder in den Beinen?
Oder?
Nee, nee, nee, alle anderen Extremitäten sind okay.
Okay.
Und haben Sie etwas Schwieres gehoben vor vier Tagen?
Nichts besonder, also nein, also nicht besonders schwer, das wüsste ich nicht.
Nein.
Okay, Herr Schall, ich habe alle wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Aus meiner Seite haben Sie Fragen an mich oder möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Nee, eigentlich als Frage natürlich, was kann man gegen diese Wahnsinnigen Kopfschmerzen machen
und was ist die Ursache davon?
Natürlich, wenn das nach vier Tagen immer noch ist, macht man sich so ein bisschen Gedanken,
was ist denn da los?
Und ja, vor allem, was können wir dagegen tun?
Wir haben bis jetzt nur Aspirin probiert.
Ja, genau.
Es gibt viele verschiedene Gründe für Kopfschmerzen.
Zuerst werde ich ein anderes Medikament versuchen.
Ich glaube, Sie haben nur wegen Stress Kopfschmerzen,
aber ich möchte durch mehrere Untersuchungen andere schwere Erkrankungen auch ausschließen.
Was machen Sie jetzt für Untersuchungen?
Neurologische Untersuchungen werde ich durchführen.
Ah ja?
Und ich nehme Ihnen Blut ab.
Und natürlich verabreiche ich Ihnen in die Wehne Schmerzmetzel.
Ah, das ist ja gut, dass ich mal diese Schmerzen los werde, dass ich mal zur Ruhe komme.
Nichts auf Polen, allergisch haben Sie keine Allergie gegen Medikamente, oder?
Nein, gegen Medikamente ist nichts bekannt bisher, ne?
Ja, sehr gut. Okay.
Ja, nehmen Sie Platz und warten Sie.
Ja, gut, dann warte ich hier.
Danke schön.
Haben Kollegen oder Kolleginnen andere Fragen?
Ich denke, es war sehr gut.
War echt top, ja, ja, ja.
Sprachlich sind Sie sehr, sehr sicher unterwegs, Frau Grenze.
Also, kein Zweifel.
Und Sie haben auch schön systematisch gemacht.
Vielleicht hätten Sie, ich weiß nicht, ein bisschen kürzer, wäre vielleicht gegangen,
aber doch Sie haben sich sehr gut durchgefragt, würde ich sagen.
Ja, aber ich denke ja sehr gut, aber weil es das Heldurfalle, deswegen, ich weiß.
Also, dann können Sie das gut einschätzen, ne?
Ja, und die Finanzielldiagnose, 33 Jahre alt, ein bisschen...
Hatte ja noch nichts gesagt, sie hat sich noch nicht geäußert.
Ja.
Sie wird gleich zum Arzt, wird sie dann ja eine Differenzialdiagnose und eine Differenzialdiagnose äußern
und dann können wir ja mal gucken, was passt.
Welcher Hand benutzt eine Frage?
Auch das wäre natürlich noch eine Frage, ob man rechts oder linkshänder ist, ne?
Kennen Sie den Begriff?
Ja, dass man sagt, jemand ist rechtshänder oder linkshänder.
Ja, ich bin linkshänder.
Und waren Sie linkshänder?
Nein, ich bin kein linkshänder.
Okay.
Immer vergesse ich eine Frage.
Ja, wobei, das ist eigentlich auch keine Standardfrage.
Das ist jetzt nur in diesem Fall interessant, weil der diese halbseitigen Kopfschmerzen eben steht.
Ja.
Ja, dann würden Sie sich schon loslegen.
Ja, ich würde...
Oder wollen Sie noch eben...
Können wir als Erzheizgeschichte anfangen?
Äh, ja.
Ich kann anfangen.
Gut.
Ja, alles klar.
Guten Abend, Frau Overhards.
Denn heute möchte ich Ihnen einen neuen Patient vorstellen.
Er ist Herr Klaus Schall.
Er ist 33 Jahre alt.
Und der Patient berichtet über seit mehrere Tagen bestehendes HFG.
4 Tage?
Ja, seit 4 Tagen.
Auf der linken Seite.
Die Schmerzen sind Brennen und Ziens.
Und sie sind erst mal auftreten.
Und sie strellen in die Schulter und in den Rücken aus.
Mhm.
Und...
Rücken?
Ich denke nicht hinterkopf.
Hinterkopf.
Okay.
Und bis auf Zittern auf der linken Hand gibt es keine weitere Beschwerde,
bezüglich diese Kopfschmerzen.
Die Schmerzintensität liegt bei 6 von 10.
Und am Anfang waren sie leichter.
Im Laufe derseits sind sie schlimmer geworden.
Er hatte keine Traumata, keinen Unfall vor 4 Tagen.
Und vegetative Anamnese ist unauffällig bis auf Schlafstörungen
wegen dieser Beschwerde.
Und er hat Tinnitus seit 5 Jahren.
Und dafür hat er einen HNO-Arzt aufgesucht.
Aber es wurde keine Erkrankung festgestellt.
Und in der Kindheit hatte sie einen Unterarmfraktur gehabt,
die operiert behandelt wurde.
Operativ behandelt wurde.
Und er hat Polenallergie und bei Bedarf nutzt er Nasenspräch.
Und er raucht seit 12 Jahren täglich 5-6 Zigarette,
also ungefähr 3 Petten, die im Kotinkonsum besteht.
Er wollte sehr selten.
Und sein Vater hatte vor 2 Jahren eine Standimplantation gehabt.
Ein Corona-Stand, oder?
Ja, Corona-Stand.
Und seine Mutter leidet unter gonadrose und hat eine totale Protein.
Er hat eine Schwester und sie ist gesund.
Er arbeitet als Angestellte in einem Büro und wohnt mit seinen Freunden.
Ich habe eine Anamnäßige Angabe am 1. Spannungskopfschmerzen.
Aber differenzial diagnostisch kommen wegen des Alltages des Patientens.
Multi-Psyclerose.
Im Has-Wir-Besäule-Bereich Diskusprolaps.
Um diese Diagnose auszuschließen, würde ich eine MRT durchführen.
Was machen Sie zunächst?
Zunächst würde ich eine neurologische Untersuchung durchführen.
Ich habe viele Fragen gestaltet, um eine akute Schlaganfall oder Insel auszuschließen.
Aber Sie machen doch trotzdem erstmal die körperliche Untersuchung.
Ja, genau.
Und im Rahmen der körperlichen Untersuchung dann die neurologische Untersuchung.
Aber wo nach gucken Sie vielleicht noch?
Wo nach gucken ich?
Vielleicht nackensteifigkeit.
Muskeln im oberen Bereich, im Rücken.
Sind Sie verspannt oder nicht?
Das ist wichtig.
Was machen Sie weiter an Untersuchung?
Sie haben schon gesagt, zum Ausschuss eines Diskusprolaps,
wollen Sie eine CT-Untersuchung?
MRT.
Oder MRT der Hals-Treh-Versäule.
Was machen Sie noch für Untersuchung?
Ich würde Entzündungs-Bulut abnehmen.
Entzündungsparameter und kleines Blutbild wäre hilfreich in diesem Fall.
Und vielleicht eine Augenart, Überweisung oder Pronsil würde ich bitten.
Augenart?
Vielleicht hat der Patient nicht bemerkt.
Durch diese Untersuchung kann man sehe.
Ach so, dass er den Sehfehler hat.
Das ist momentan kein Muss, aber vielleicht nach der neurologischen Untersuchung kann man.
Okay, da weiß man ein bisschen mehr.
Ja, sehr gut.
Dann halten Sie mich bitte auf dem Laubenden,
das bei den Untersuchungen vom Herrn Schalder rausgekommen ist.
Der kann aber nach Hause gehen, wenn die Untersuchungen durch sind, oder?
Ja, wenn sie nicht auffällig ist.
Auch wenn die Untersuchungen nicht auffällig sind.
Wenn die Untersuchungen nicht auffällig wären,
würde ich mit einem Rezept nach Hause schicken.
Aber zuerst würde ich einen Insel ausschließen.
Okay, ja.
Gut, ja, sehr schön.
Ich würde mal sagen, das war eine sehr überzeugende Vorstellung.
Sie haben das wunderbar gemacht.
Es ist mir nicht mal irgendwas aufgefallen,
dass sie irgendwas auch grammatikalisch,
jetzt ein groben Fehler drin,
irgendwann habe ich mal korrigiert direkt.
Was Dr. Gündig schon gesagt hat,
die Ausstrahlung hat ja beschrieben,
der Schmerz in den Hinterkopf
und in den linke Schulter und linken Arm.
Also nicht in den Rücken.
Ja, nicht in den Rücken.
Ja, und ich habe als,
ja, was meinen Sie, was habe,
ja, genau,
was habe ich denn jetzt tatsächlich,
die hier vorgegebene Diagnose,
was meinen Sie, was wäre richtig?
Also es ist nicht der Spannungskopfschmerz.
Ach, Therapie, was würde ich machen?
Nein, nein, die Diagnose, welche Diagnose?
Welche Diagnose nach dem Fall,
den wir ja alle schon kennen,
was war die richtige Diagnose?
Eine Sache haben Sie nicht mehr nachgefragt.
Er hat gesagt, er arbeitet im Büro,
im Einwohner-Meldeamt,
und er arbeitet am Computer.
Und er ist 83 Jahre alt,
wahrscheinlich verbringt er auch sonst den Rest des Tages,
relativ viel Zeit am Computer.
Und?
Ja, Muskelentspannung.
Ja, also der hat möglicherweise eben ein HWS-Syndrom.
Das ist ein Syndrom, meinst Ihr, HWS-Syndrom.
Genau, ja.
Und also unter dieser Diagnose läuft dieser Fall.
Ja.
Und vielleicht doch als Hinweis,
ganz klar angegeben,
halbseitiger Kopfschmerz,
allerdings ohne sonstige Aura-Symptome,
Migräne sollte man nicht ganz außer Acht lassen.
Wenn jemand halbseitig den Kopfschmerz schildert,
dass man an Migräne denkt,
wobei sie eigentlich schon die entscheidenden Fragen gestellt haben,
haben sie Sehstörungen gehabt
und was, was ich kein erbrechen.
Dann, und auch über vier Tage dauernd,
ist sehr unwahrscheinlich,
dass sie wirklich Migräne hätte.
Aber das war hier immer noch als einer,
als eine der Differenzialdiagnose in dem Fall genannt.
Ja.
Ich habe Cluster, auch an Cluster-Kopfschmerzen gedacht,
aber vegetative Symptome fehlen.
Deswegen ist es auch unwahrscheinlich,
in diesem Fall keine nächtige Schmerzen und so weiter.
Gut.
Ja, also, wann haben Sie Ihre Prüfung?
Am nächsten, am 21.
20.
Ja, also fast eine Woche.
Und zu, das wird, das wird was.
Ja, dann möchte man ja wirklich seine Hand für uns heuer leben.
Ja, doch.
Also, Sie haben das sehr, sehr schön gemacht.
Und das ist ja gut.
Dann haben wir uns gerade noch rechtzeitig vorher getroffen
und gehen Sie mit einem guten Gefühl in die Brut her.
Ja, danke schön.
Und alle anderen,
gehen Sie mit,